I can't imagine after the election you  didn't say I need someone to talk to  I've read a really sweet moment after  this horror of the night you and your  husband laid down at night you're laying  on your back he's laying on his back and  he takes your hand and holds your hand  right yeah that's it are you gonna make  me cry no it's the most sweet well  gesture what else can you do  yeah he's been a terrific you know it  support this gesture by your husband to  just sit and hold your hand it's an  important moment right because there's  nothing to say after you after you've  work your ass off your whole life to get  to this presidency and and and was that  the dream when you were a little girl  with that you would someday be the  present in the United States